hey everyone it's sarah register nurse
rn.com and in this video we're going to
talk about
medication administration routes and
their abbreviations
so let's get started as a nursing
student or new nurse you want to be
familiar with these abbreviations
because you know you may be on the floor
and you may hear some other nurse say oh
the physician
ordered that po or i need to give this i
am or iv
or sub q etc and you want to be familiar
with
how that route is used to administer
medications
now one thing you want to remember about
abbreviations like whenever you're
documenting or you're taking orders
is that you're using approved
abbreviations set
by your employer most employers will
have a list of abbreviations that you
can use whenever you're documenting or
taking orders
because some abbreviations can have
multiple meanings and they want to
prevent medical errors
and if you're ever in doubt about an
abbreviation you can always just write
it out
first let's talk about medication
administration routes that deal
with the mouth so a very popular term
you're going to hear in nursing is
p o and p o simply stands for a latin
term called peros and what this means is
by the mouth through the mouth and this
is a very popular way to give
medications
we give many tablets capsules and liquid
medications
through this route then we have the
sublingual route and the abbreviation
for this
is sl so sub means under and lingual
means
tongue so we give the medication
underneath the tongue now a medication
you may encounter as a nurse that goes
under the tongue is like
nitroglycerin so if your patient's
having acute chest pain and it's ordered
you can give them
a nitroglycerin tablet and hopefully
that will help relieve their chest pain
another route we can give through the
mouth is called the buccal route
and it's abbreviated bucc and this is
where you place the medication in
between the cheek
and the gum so we're giving this through
the transmucosal route
and some medications that can be given
this way are certain forms
of opioid pain medication smoking
cessation products and etc
and since we're talking about the mouth
i want to throw this out there so
another popular term that you're going
to hear in nursing
is npo so what this is is again it's
latin and it means nil per oats
and that just means nothing by mouth
so po was bi-mouth but when you put the
n in front of it it means that the
patient can have nothing by mouth
now let's talk about medication
administration routes where we give the
medication directly into the vein
now to do this the patient is going to
need iv access
in a vein somewhere usually on their
arms
and you're going to see a very popular
term known as iv
and iv stands for intravenous so
whenever you're giving anything iv
you're giving it directly into that vein
through
some type of iv access now some other
lingo you may hear about whenever we're
talking about the
venus route is like iv piggyback and
it's abbreviated ivpb
so with this what we're doing is we have
a main line of fluids running let's say
it's like normal saline
and then we're going to hang another bag
it's going to have shorter tubing and
it's going to hence piggyback
or connect into that main line of tubing
with the normal saline in it
and usually what we do this with is like
antibiotics
and then another common way we can give
directly into the vein
is through an iv push so intravenous
push you may see it abbreviated
ivp and this is where we draw the
medication up
in a syringe and we push it into their
iv
access now let's talk about medication
administration routes that use an
injection or the skin to
deliver medication to a patient's body
so one way we can deliver medication is
through the im
route im stands for intramuscular and we
give many vaccines
even some types of antibiotic and
hormone therapy
through the muscle another route is
through the subcutaneous route and this
is where we use
the fat within the skin's tissue now
it's abbreviated as
sub cube so some medications that you
will encounter as a nurse that will be
administered sub-q
or like insulin or anticoagulants like
heparin and enoxaparin which is known as
lovenox then we have the intradermal
route and it is abbreviated
id now this isn't as common
as let's say the sub q route or the im
route
but this is where an injection can be
given into the dermis which is found
between the epidermis
and the hypodermis so what can be given
this way are like
allergy tests or the mantu
skin test which is the tb test to test
for tuberculosis
and as you can see here in this picture
this patient is getting
this test and they're giving it via the
intradermal injection
and notice that their skin hence bubbles
up
it creates a wheel and then lastly we
have the transdermal route
now this is not given via injection
instead something is placed
on top of the skin now this is
abbreviated as
td so medications that we can give via
this route are like medicated patches or
ointments
that are applied to that top surface of
the skin so we're placing it on the
epidermis and it's going to be absorbed
into the bloodstream
now some medications that you may
administer like this are
pain relief medications like fentanyl
patches
and if you work on a cardiac unit like
nitro
cream like the nitro bib that you can
put on the chest to help with chest pain
now let's talk about some miscellaneous
medication administration routes that
you are going to encounter as a nurse
so one way is through the inhalation
route so in held and it's abbreviated
inh
now with these medications that require
this they will enter into the
respiratory tract so any inhaler your
patient may be prescribed
or nebulizers like breathing treatments
and you'll see respiratory therapy
administer these types of treatments
many times next is the intraosseous
route and this is known as the io route
now this isn't very common because it's
used in emergency
situations and this is where access is
placed in the marrow of the bone
so they may use this site whenever
there's a code blue
situation and you can't obtain iv access
it's like felt so they can give
medications and fluids through this
route which is going to enter into the
vascular system
and then we have the endotracheal tube
route
so if your patient has an endotracheal
tube
medications can be given through this
but this is just for emergency
situations
whenever access can't really be obtained
any other way
so what you'll be giving is like
emergency type drugs through it
and you'll see it abbreviated ett and
medications will be instilled through
this and they'll be absorbed through the
alveoli
and will cross over into the bloodstream
now only certain medications can be
given
through this breathing tube and
how you can remember it is you can
remember the word laned
so lidocaine atropine naloxone
epinephrine and diazepam the eyes are
also another route that can be used to
administer medications
now whenever using this route you'll
want to write out the word i
and you want to designate which eye like
the right eye the left eye
or both eyes now they no longer
recommend
using the abbreviations o s
o d or o u to abbreviate for this route
because
it can get confused with other routes in
addition the ear can be
used as a route of medication
administration as well
and just like with the eye it's best to
write this
route out and designate is it the right
ear
the left ear or both ears before
asad and au were abbreviations used for
this route but that is no longer
recommended
medications can also be given through
the rectum and you can see this
abbreviated
r e c t or p r p
r stands for per rectum in addition
medications can be ordered vaginally so
you may see this
abbreviated vag or pvm pv stands for
per vagina medications can also be
instilled in
the nose so nasally so the patient can
have some type of medication order
nasally where you would just squirt
the prescribed male in each nostril
and lastly medications can also be
administered through
some type of tube like a feeding tube so
one way is through a nasogastric tube
you may see this abbreviated
in gt and this is where a tube is
inserted
through the nose down into the esophagus
and into
the stomach and another popular way is
through a
peg tube peg stands for percutaneous
endoscopic gastrostomy and this is where
a tube
is inserted surgically so they insert it
through the skin and it sets
inside the stomach okay so that wraps up
this video on the different types of
medication administration routes and
their abbreviations
now don't forget to access the free quiz
that will test you on this material